[موسيقى]
من مصر سالنا الناس عن المعلمين الذين
تركوا اثرا كبيرا في حياتهم متابعه
والله يا معلم
كل الحياه الجميله فيهم
بصراحه حاجات كثيره يعني موجوده في قلبي
يعني
بصراحه مدرسين الابتدائي كلهم يعني عندك
مستر امجد مثلا بسم الله ما شاء الله
خرجنا كلنا حابين الرياضه وكان جميل وكان
واخدنا كلنا كاولاد كاخواته بسم الله ما
شاء الله غير مدرسين بصراحه دلوقتي
يعني كان طيب جدا وكان عنده يعني
طاقه انه هيتقبل الغلط ويعلم ويصحها من
غير ما يغلط في اي طالب
كويس جدا وبيعتبرنا زي عياله برده كان
بيقعد ينصحنا يعني حاجه بره بتعليمه وكده
يدينا نصايح في حياتنا كان مدرس الرياضه
بتاعي انا كنت باحبش ال- همم المسائل
الحسابيه وهو كان دائما بمعاملته كويسه
معي
دائما استقباله تشجيع لي ده خلاني احب
طبعا الماده وانا ما كنتش بحبها يعني
[موسيقى]